オーケー、みんなドーガンここに
いるから日本のコンビニエンス
ストアが信じられないほど素晴らしいことはみんな知っているので
、この機会に今日の
日本のコンビニエンス ストアで得たものを皆さんにお見せしたいと思います。
-エイズ
今日は指を切りました にんじんを切ろうとしていたのですが、日本で
すぐに自分を治す
ために知っているものを手に入れることができるのは素晴らしいことだと思います
私が日本を好きな理由 私はこれらの卵サンドイッチの 1 つを持っています
日本人はいつもこれらの卵サンドイッチを食べ
たことがありません 私はこれまでにこれらの卵サンドイッチを実際に食べたことがありません
試し
てみ
ましょう これが
私が日本を本当に愛している理由です.
これは驚くべきことであり、それはクレイジーなドルのよう
でした.その上、私は
日本が非常に健康であることで知られ
ていることを意味します. これはあなたが
毎日のように知っていることかもしれません
が、オートミールやブルーベリーなどの代替品よりもはるかに優れ
ている可能性があるので、日本を愛しています。
ほうじ茶って言う すごくいい匂いがする
うーん
みんな日本人みたいに ええと
香り
私が以前に食べていた食品に潜在的な欠点
があったとしても 私はそうではないと確信し
ています
このほうじ茶は薬のように飲んで
いるようなものです.10年か15年ほど年齢を戻すような研究がいくつかあります.
私が
言っていることだと
思います. このような
ボトルのことは、あなたが洗練されていることを知っ
ているようで、
スコットのようにこの遊び心のあるキャラクターが好きであることを意味し
ます。コカ・コーラを知っていることとはまったく異なり
ます
もうちょっと頑張ってみて
えーと伊藤さんに習ってください おわり
このコースに彼らが取り入れた職人技を本当に感じますか
次の項目
はええと、コンビニエンス ストアから入手したこの靴下
です。 雑誌
とかお菓子
とか本格的なアパレルショップみたいな感じ 両方の
長所 漢字全部読めない
けど開けてみて
ストレッチが効いてるみたい
ああ、好きだ、好きだ、これを
着るつもりだ、そうそう、そうそう、
それらは気分が良いが、それはきっと
、日本人のような伝統的
な縫製技術の
ようなものだろう私はアメリカに戻ることはできない
この信じられないほどのものすべてに慣れている 靴下
バンドエイドが来る
プロテインパックに入ったこれらのええとプロテインの1つも手に入れました 体の状態を改善するために毎日の運動をサポートするための、より吸収されやすいペプチドとして
タンパク質を供給するように設計された特別なゼリードリンク わかり
ませ
ん 100 なんて つまり
、海外のアクション パックが大好きです。
これは、健康食品のように、おいしい人が味わうことができるようなもの
です。日本でこれらの短所を読めたらいいのにと思います。日本が大好きなので、
これは本当に楽しみです。
私は実際に
ドイツの血を持っています.ほとんど
の視聴者はこれを知っているとは思いませんが
、ドイツの血を持つ人として、私は
この種のことの
権威の
ようなものです. アメリカに戻ってきた本物と同じように
ここに
行きますオーマイゴッドオーケー
ここで少し時間をとってくださいこれは本物よりも優れて
います私がこれを言っているとは信じられません
がオーマイゴッド私が試したすべて
今日もバンドエイドのような
ものです 靴下はとても
快適です プロテインパックはとても快適
です つまり、高校で武道をしていたときにそれを持って
いたら、黒帯のように簡単に取得できたかもしれませ
ん 数ヶ月前に
大丈夫だから、あといくつかの食料品を持っているので、
これらをチェックしましょう ut ピーナッツバターサンドウィッチ
でもそれはあなたがうまくいかないからクレイジーです 私はただあなたたち
にこれを説明する方法がわかりませんが
、パンにはクラストがありません
ええと、明らかに日本の
ピーナッツのようです 私たちは 読め
ない 漢字全部読めないけど
気にしなくていいし 食べても罪悪感なく
ていい
よ 健康な
国 日本人がこれを食べて永遠に生きているのを見
ている 私の血糖値が急上昇していることを知っているかどうか、今は心配していません 私は
日本が大好きです これを
10個くらい食べてもまだ続けられ
そうな気がします 私はこれを見て、これ
はとてもクールだと思いました。
小さな小さなメモ帳
のように、
素晴らしい考えがあり
、それを書き留めたいと思うことが何度もありますが、その後は書き留めません。 何も持っ
てないからコンビニに行けば分かるって嬉しい
ｗ ヒッチは再び非常に近くにあり
、これらのいずれかを選択すると、それは大丈夫
ですアイデアを思いつきましたそれを引き出しましょうブームああ
、それはとても簡単に乗ることができます何
を書けばいいですか
私は日本が好きです私
は好きではありません私は
お父さんが好きです
禅のミニマリストの美学が好きです
これが私が日本の好きなところです
人々は実際にまだ何かを書い
ているようです とてもクールです 私はそれ
が恋しいです 日本の
どのコンビニエンス ストアでも、この信じられないほどのものをすべて手に入れることができます
。Bandit を手に入れました。怪我をするかどうか心配する必要はありません。
どこに行っても小さな病院のよう
なものです。 日本をもっと褒めてもらえ
ませ
んか この靴下 この靴下 この靴下 コンビニに行くたびに この靴下を
履いて ニンバスに乗っているような気分で
このような運搬をすることで 日本への愛が強まります
pe への私の愛の国
今日のレジの人のことです
彼女は実際にネパール出身だったと思います
これらの色を見てください それは
私が日本の好きなところです あなた
は文化とすべてと
卵サンドイッチと爆弾のように感じることができます クールハンド
大丈夫ですが ここでビデオを終わらせ
ないといけません 始め
たら感情
的になってしまいます 日本について話すとこんな感じになります このアメリカで
20年間の人生をどのように過ごしたの
ですか
あそこのすべてが馬鹿げて
いるようで後ろ向きだアメリカのすべてが嫌いだったように
アメリカには
何も良い
ことがないようにそれはただ愚かだ私はそれが好きで
はないし、私は帰りたくない私は本当に
日本を愛しているので それだけでなく、私は
ここに来られてうれしいです。ええと、これはいかが
ですか。日本を高く評価してください。日本を愛しているなら
、親指を立ててください。それから、サブスクライブもお願い
します。またすぐにこれを行うことができます。 私たちは
日本の食料品店のように行きます
日本人のようになってください
私たちは何かを考え出します 私は日本にい
ます ええ わかり
ました ではここでビデオを終了し
ます money
うーん
oh oh シュート オッケー ラブ ジャパン ラブ ジャパン